back in Russia after a seven-year ban
these women had almost forgotten how
Georgian wine tastes even Georgian
restaurants like this one in Moscow
haven't been allowed to serve it since
2006 the official line being that it was
impure this was a case of politics
interfering in our daily lives it wasn't
right I like to drink Georgian wine in
particular to accompany a Georgian meal
this big enormous keep our Russian
visitors missed the wine from my home
and the Georgian vintners missed the
Russian market with a video Georgian
wine has returned to Russian
supermarkets to before the ban eighty
percent of Georgian wine went to Russia
seven years later however it's proving
difficult to make a comeback what's not
normal Brzezinski before the ban
Georgian wine competed mainly with wine
from Moldova and Ukraine now the range
is much larger in Russia there are wines
from all over the world to choose from
extra aveli yoga which offers 12
varieties of Georgian wine at his
restaurant and he hopes that the return
of the wine will mark the beginning of
lasting reconciliation between the two
countries